[Music]
from reopenings to
openings there are a lot of changes from
the strip to downtown las vegas
and we're seeing many of those changes
for the very first time
including resorts world orco mana
joining us live from there now with a
look at how these resorts are doing
orco well brian in less than one month
resorts world here will open its doors
for the very first time the property is
really
starting to take shape here on the strip
and with virgin and circa
already off the ground for entering an
exciting era for las vegas despite the
pandemic
[Music]
the entertainment capital of the world
is expanding las vegas welcoming new
resorts even amid
coveted 19.
virgin hotels las vegas formerly the
hard rock opened in late march
so how's business it's as expected
richard boz bosworth president of the
property's ownership group tells me
operations are not quite at pre-pandemic
levels
but the future looks promising our hotel
reservation is interesting enough now
as we work through the softness and as
we see a light at the end of the tunnel
with kovid
are now starting to pick up
significantly not only for may and june
but for the second half of the year
downtown it's hard to miss circa the
first resort to open during the pandemic
back in october
it's great to see the demand owner
derrick stevens says reservations are
ramping up
now that there are little to no covert
restrictions i've never seen eight weeks
of
booking trends like what we're seeing
here what he looked like going out to
june july
august through the rest of the year it's
really been outstanding
up next is resorts world slated to open
june 24th it'll be the first new resort
completed on the las vegas strip
in more than a decade we're like in the
ninth inning of a baseball game
and we're almost there president scott
sabella hopes its state of the art
technology and list of impressive
residencies will bring a business boom
to the north end of the strip
but with five thousand employees still
needed it's a huge undertaking
we're excited and again it won't happen
overnight but business will shift this
way
in the future i think this will be the
luxury side of the strip as far as what
visitors want at the new resorts
a cool pool and a nice bar a different
experience makes people want to come
back
so that's what i'm looking for
the new property is promising to meet
those expectations and thrilled to be
doing it together
with us and circa and resorts world and
to be able to
renew that that statute within the
entertainment industry for the community
worldwide i look forward to that as well
[Music]
and i can tell you all of las vegas is
rooting for these three properties to
succeed
again resorts world here is scheduled to
open on june
24th reporting live near the las vegas
strip tonight orca man
8 news now